eventually people will get I suppose
population under control but there is a
large and growing number of people they
all have to be fed they all have to be
housed they all have to learn they're
all going to have families we hope
they're all going to have lives each one
of them is an individual life and as you
have more and more you've got the great
positive thing is is people there it's
it's it's religion if you like but I
mean people have within them the
capacity for great good and for terrible
things and and and societies come
together with churches come together
philosophers come together people come
together with sets of behaviors which we
try to teach children so that they'll
get those bad instincts on to control
and so will bring out the good ones and
if you can bring out the goons people
are capable of marvelous things I mean
just tremendous organization so well I
that's why I thought India was so
interesting because I thought my
goodness it's like a microcosm I'm here
we have the points of light and the
dangers of darkness and of course we all
know now we can destroy the whole planet
it's possible it's possible and yet
we're working and that's why I'm so
enthusiastic about these different
organizations whether they're local or
whether they're national or whether
they're they're they're they're
international that are trying to knit
things together they're trying to create
structures so when future people are
born in the world they will have
structures within which they can work to
try to use their good instincts their
capacities their abilities to create
worlds that are better and if you
contrast this century with the 19th in
the 19th they were certain that it was
progress but we've lived through I have
and you know this terrible terrible 20th
century and now people are not at all
certain whether the forces of progress
whether the good within people is so
good that it can overcome these
tremendous problems but we're working on
it so I'm an optimist and most people
are we work on it we do our best